Grand Admiral Thon was born in nobody
and Rose to become the Galaxy's greatest
threat but how here's the whole story
behind the latest big bat in the Star
Wars
franchise though Thon was introduced in
Timothy zon's now non-canonical 1991
novel air to the Empire fans learned
more about the character's origin story
in Zan's 2017 canonical reboot thraw as
well as the thraw ascendancy Trilogy
which was released between 2020 and
2021 a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away the man later
known as Thon was originally named kivu
Ruru or vuran the son of the lower class
kevu family and a member of the chis
race he was born on the planet rentor
around 59 years before the Battle of
Yavin for reference this is about the
same time that Quon Jinn became a Jedi
Knight and just a few years before the
birth of Obi-Wan Kenobi the chis are
biologically similar to humans except
for their distinctive blue skin and
striking red eyes these mutations may
have developed after their region of
space was all but cut off from the rest
of the Galaxy many thousands of years
ago the chis rule over a portion of the
unknown regions an area beyond the outer
rim that has long been considered
mysterious and treacherous due to the
highly unusual Cosmic phenomena that
occur there the chis navigate the
unknown regions with the help of
temporarily for sensitive chis children
called Skywalkers K ruru's older sister
was one of these Skywalkers the siblings
were separated early in their childhood
which had a profound effect on
Veron the hyper intelligent Veron made a
name for himself at the Academy on
rentor though he hailed from humble
beginnings his performance attracted the
attention of powerful chis leaders
including myth aord the head of the
powerful myth family in 39 BBY Veron was
formally accepted into the myth family
as a merit adoptive which essentially
means that the myths took in Veron based
solely on his potential this involved a
process known as rematching which
included a ceremony and a change of name
during which kibu Ruru became myth Ruru
this also meant that promising student
Thon would be expected to serve the Chis
ascendency in a more important capacity
he was transferred from rentor to the
taram Academy on the planet napar where
Cadets trained to prepare for service in
the newly formed chis expansionary
defense Fleet the journey marked the
first time thraw had ever flown in space
but it would hardly be the last from
approximately 37 BBY to 19 BBY Thon Rose
within the ranks of the chis military
during these years he cemented his
reputation as a leader who would take
risks if it might mean Victory and this
included going on the offensive since
preemptive strikes went against the chis
Honor Code thon's command style became a
strength and a liability to the
ascendancy it wasn't long before he was
promoted again this time to senior
captain and given a new honorific suffix
making him Mithra Nuru
Odo thraw first meets a character from
the liveaction Star Wars Universe in the
2018 book thrawn
alliances this is where the fun begins
with the Clone Wars already well
underway Padme amadala and her handmade
in duja traveled to Batu on a secret
mission when her husband Anakin
Skywalker learns that her ship has been
found empty he goes looking for her
along the way he crosses paths with Thon
Thon who was ever hungry to gather
intelligence that might help in the chis
ascendancy's war against the alien grisk
makes a deal with the Jedi he'll help
Anakin find Padme if Anakin will debrief
him on the intricacies of the Clone Wars
the unlikely Duo is soon ambushed at
black Spire Outpost and thraw determines
that separatists are plotting to
assassinate Anakin meanwhile duja is
murdered when she discovers an enemy
Droid Factory and base thraw and Anakin
investigate get themselves captured free
themselves and eventually meet up with
Padme ultimately though it becomes clear
that thraw and Anakin have different
goals the chis want to steal a
deflective shield generator while the
Republic wants to blow up the factory
Anakin takes Things One Step too far and
bombss a m too which Thon and Padme deem
a serious diplomatic error nevertheless
Thon and Anakin part on friendly terms
and their time together on Batu pays
dividends for Thon later in his
life thon's personal philosophy may have
been riskier and more aggressive than
most chess but on the whole He favored
careful planning over Reckless violence
these two facets of his personality set
thron up for the mission that would
change the course of his life as he
continues to wage war on the grisk th
meets some neimoidians who have survived
the Clone Wars they proposed the chis
fight the newly formed Galactic Empire
alongside the remnants of the Trade
Federation sensing that Emperor
Palpatine might turn out to be a better
Ally than the neans thraw hatches a plan
in the 2018 comic Star Wars thrawn
number one the chis Captain arranges to
have himself stripped of his title and
exiled to Wild space his intention is to
be found by Imperial forces gain their
trust and infiltrate their ranks all for
his people's benefit
after a few months in 15 BBY Thon
Attacks An Imperial scouting party and
allows himself to be captured and
questioned he is quite honest about the
preemptive strike that led to his
supposed banishment but lies about
having lived at his encampment for 5
years after impressing his captors Thon
is taken by Captain Park and Cadet vono
to corusant to be presented as a gift to
Emperor Palpatine Thon quickly offers
himself to the Empire as a resource
knowledgeable about the unknown regions
Palpatine accepts and welcomes thrawn
into the Imperial Navy for a while thraw
sees himself as a double agent and
assumes he will spend about a year in
the Empire service but that's not
exactly what
happens though he served as a formidable
chis strategist with Decades of
experience under his belt Thon is sent
to the Royal Imperial Academy for about
3 months he forms an instant rapport
with Emperor Palpatine who is curious
about the unknown regions and shares
thon's appreciation for fine things in
life but within both the academy and the
ranks of the Empire's Navy Thon is not
as well-liked he endures a significant
amount of harassment mostly due to his
alien appearance but also partly because
of his smug attitude for the second time
in his life Thon graduates as a
lieutenant and vono is assigned to act
as his Aid it isn't long before Thon is
back to his old habits displaying the
kind of ambitious aggression that had
long irritated his chis overseers
despite irking his Imperial superiors as
well Thon almost always comes out on top
in just a few short years Thon is
promoted from Lieutenant to Captain to
First officer to Commander serving on
the ship's blood Crow and thunder wasp
but as he outshines his superiors he
creates adversaries too to help himself
politically he makes frequent visits to
corusant where he ingratiates himself
with the Empire's movers and shakers
including wolf yarin and Orinda
price because thon's story exists in so
many forms it can be tricky to pin down
exactly when certain events took place
as especially if dates aren't
specifically mentioned in the texts or
TV shows based on context clues however
we can guess that Thon was given control
of the chimira around 12 BBY after about
4 years of service Thon and bonto are
called back to corusant without
explanation for once Thon finds himself
honored instead of reprimanded or
scrutinized he's made Commodore and
given the Run of a star destroyer the
ISD Chima upon which he emblazons his
personal symbol becomes his ship from
then on thron's close Associates benefit
from his rapid Ascension too vanto is
promoted to Lieutenant Commander and
Orinda price is named the new governor
of her home planet lothal at this time
Commodore thron is also introduced to
Grand Moff Tarkin Charming to the last
Commodore thron and his crew aboard the
Chimera are quickly tasked with sussing
out a burgeoning rebel Insurgency one of
their leaders who goes by the code name
night swan has long been a thorn in
thon's
side Thon is promoted from commodor to
ad Admiral after crushing a rebellion on
bodaff he then receives his final
promotion After figuring out the
identity of night Swan and putting a
stop to another revolt and in true Thon
fashion he does it all while
disrespecting his high command the
Empire discovers a rebel movement
spreading across planets such as baton
and lothal Thon is initially placed in
charge of crushing an Insurgency on
baton but he turns down the job because
he doesn't feel there is enough
intelligence to ensure Victory he's
right too however as the insert fly to
their mobile base thron follows there he
arranges for vono to be captured as
thron predicts vono is brought before
their leader Neville signey or nwan the
chimira returns to Baton and threatens
the insurgents sigy and Thon meet to
negotiate and realize they have much in
common including their preference to
minimize loss of life in battle Thon
even reveals to signey that he is still
loyal to the chis and not necessarily
the Empire and attempts to lure him to
his personal cause in in the end however
an explosion on baton set off by
Governor Price kills countless civilians
including signey though the bomb wasn't
his doing the strategy leading up to it
was and Thon reaps the reward Thon is
invited to appear before the Emperor who
names him Grand
Admiral the Imperial Navy may have
silenced the Rebellion on baton but
lothal still poses a serious problem
it's at this point that non-book and
non-comic readers will meet the grand
Admiral as he's sent to deal with the
Freedom Fighters of Star Wars Rebels
at the beginning of the third season
Thon steps in to hunt down Phoenix
Squadron and secure the region for the
empire for two seasons he uses his
intellect as a strategist and his
affinity for art and culture to match
wits with the rebels and in particular
the crew of the ghost Bron connects dots
in several ways to put together a better
picture of the Insurgency he faces for
example he is able to keep tabs on them
thanks to Sabine Ren's graffiti and he
tricks hero andula with his knowledge of
Twilight totems even when he loses he
wins
after the rebels successfully bombb a
star destroyer thraw takes a few steps
closer to uncovering the location of
their hidden base the rebels have won
this
battle but the war will be
ours Thon also identifies a traitor in
the Empire's ranks agent Alexander
Callis had been turned toward the rebel
cause aiding them under the code name
fulcrum Callis would eventually Escape
his grasp but this Revelation leads to
the discovery of the rebel base on
adelon which is soon followed by a
decisive Imperial Victory there some of
the most recent Star Wars stories
revolve around one fateful decision that
asra Bridger makes in the series finale
of Star Wars Rebels when Governor price
destroyed the fuel station on lothal and
killed Jedi Kan and jerus she also
weakened the Empire's position on the
planet with the battle at something of a
stalemate and the fate of lothal hanging
in the balance Ezra puts his plan into
action he surrenders to Thon who brings
him aboard the Chima the grand Admiral
thinks he finally has the upper hand as
he tells Ezra that he doesn't really
want to lay waste to the planet after a
brief interlude with Emperor Palpatine
Ezra manages to corner thrawn on the
bridge of the Chima and it's then that
Captain pelan radios to report that
Imperial ships are being destroyed and
that something has materialized from
hyperspace Ezra had summoned perill
enormous space fairing creatures that
resemble a cross between a whale and a
giant squid when they arrive he uses the
force to compel them to attack the Chima
as one wraps it tentacles around the
grand Admiral himself Thon realizes he
has been defeated with the ship and its
inhabitants in their grasp the perill
disappear into
hyperspace um was that the plan
curiously during the assault on adelon
months earlier Thon had taunted an
injured bendu who foresaw his demise I
see your defeat like many arms
surrounding you in a cold
Embrace after Thon and Ezra go missing
the Empire turns its attention away from
the tie Defender program the grand
Admiral had been spearheading on lothal
the emperor Grand Moff Tarkin and Darth
Vader fully commit to project Stardust
and decide they must Stamp Out The Rebel
Alliance once and for all you probably
know what happens over the next four to
5 years of the Star Wars timeline the
Rebel Alliance launches A desperate
mission to steal the Death Star plans
followed by Jedi ENT training Luke
Skywalker Landing the blow that destroys
the deadly space station The Empire
Strikes Back the rebels make a final
stand over Endor and luk helps his
father see the error of his ways by the
end of Return of the Jedi the second
death star has been destroyed marking
the dawn of a new era in Galactic
history here's a question though would
all this have turned out differently if
thron hadn't been Spirited Away from the
skies above loal his reputation and
track record suggest so had he been
present during the heist on scarth he
may have been able to Halt the domino
effect that led to the Empire's collapse
had he been by the emperor's side he may
have cautioned against the construction
of a second Death Star as he was always
skeptical about placing the majority of
the Empire's resources into one project
his disappearance also makes a potential
alliance with the chis less likely if
not entirely impossible the fact that
thraw was taken off the board during the
final years of the Galactic Civil War no
doubt gave the rebels a much better
chance at
success before he died Palpatine
constructed a secret Observatory and
computer lab on jaku which housed his
contingency plan that Plan called for
Imperial forces to flee to the known
regions along a path he' personally
charted the so-called contingency
becomes necessary when in 5ab y the new
Republic wins a month-long battle on
jaku after which the Empire concedes and
the Galactic Civil War comes to an end
as we see in the Mandalorian and Ahsoka
many of those who'd only half-heartedly
supported the emperor switch sides once
he is gone or supposedly gone at least
but we're not there just yet others
still loyal to the Empire hide in cells
across the known Galaxy ready to rise up
when called upon meanwhile many of the
highest ranking members including the
hux family flee to the unknown regions
using Palpatine's directions the
Imperial Remnant begins to rebuild there
on planets such as IL which will later
be transformed into Star Killer base
much of the sequel Trilogy takes place
in the unknown regions precisely because
the first order which emerged from the
Imperial Remnant gained power as it came
to understand and control this once
mysterious sector of space at the same
time the New Republic begins to form its
government they get a good few years out
of it too before everything gets a bit
explody Theon story picks up once more
in the Mandalorian which is set in
approximately 9 AB Y in Chapter 13
Ahsoka Tano tracks down the villainous
Morgan elth to elicit information about
thon's whereabouts when she appears in
the Mandalorian Morgan is acting as the
magistrate of corvis but she is clearly
already allied with Thon at this point
notably her droids are marked with
Chimera symbols though Gideon is that
series's Chief antagonist the
Mandalorian begins to suggest that a
greater threat to the new Republic is
looming somewhere offc screen
confirmation comes in the form of
Captain pelan and the shadow Council who
appear as Holograms in chapter 23 the
shadow Council comes together after the
fall of the Empire with two goals in
mind bring the various factions loyal to
the empire together and conceal the fact
that a threat to the new Republic exists
at all MF Gideon calls them to order to
request backup as he's about to defend
his forge on Mandalore from the recently
United Clans he Snidely points out that
grand Admiral Thon is conspicuously
absent from their meeting as usual and
wonders aloud whether it's time for new
leadership Captain pelan who served
under Thon during his time fighting
Phoenix Squadron reminds him our one
hope for Success relies upon the secrecy
of his return this strongly implies that
either pelan is in contact with the
grand Admiral or that he has reason to
believe thraw is alive and will reemerge
to to lead the fractured
Empire Morgan elth and Ahsoka Tano also
hold out hope that the Chimera and its
crew might be found the efforts to find
them serve as the main plot of the
Disney plus series Ahsoka we learned
that Morgan is a member of the
nightsisters and Order of force wielding
women sometimes refer to as the witches
of damir Ahsoka steals the supposed star
map that leads to thron and by extension
Ezra Morgan steals it back and she balen
skull and his Apprentice shinh hati all
travel to an mention ruin on seos with
the map in its proper place Morgan
believes she can hear thon's call across
time and space the massive hyperspace
ring she has built known as the eye of
Canan is intended to allow her to reach
peridia a planet located in an entirely
separate Galaxy from the one scen in the
Star Wars franchise with her ship
grounded Ahsoka considers destroying the
map to prevent the return of the
presumed air to the Empire Sabine can't
bring herself to do it however as the
map's destruction would also leave Ezra
stranded forever Ever After Ahsoka is
defeated by Balin Sabine gives up the
map surrenders and joins the villains on
a journey beyond the
Galaxy the mystery surrounding Grand
Admiral thraw and Ezra bridger's fate is
resolved in part six of Ahsoka titled
far far away that the two characters
survived their Intergalactic Journey was
never really a doubt the details however
were still up in the air at least until
the eye of Canan transports Morgan eleth
balen skull shinha and a captive Sabine
Ren to their exact location as the show
had heavily foreshadowed Thon is indeed
living on peridia and he has been there
for more than 10 years he still has his
ship the Chimera though it's looking a
little worse for wear and he still has
an army of Stormtroopers at his command
who are more loyal to him than ever oh
honor to make the sacrifice for you you
might have noticed that without a way to
replace their broken parts and armor
thon's forces have taken to using a
method of repair that greatly resembles
the Japanese practice of kin sui the use
of gold to repair that famously draws
attention to the beauty found in
imperfection during his time in Exile
fron makes judicious use of Pur as night
sisters these magic wielding witches
have Allied themselves with the grand
Admiral and their powers likely helped
them survive on peridia at the very
least he needed their help communicating
with his home Galaxy notably their siren
calls to Morgan eleth and possibly
Captain pellan acted as the first step
in thon's master plan for their part the
night sisters plan to return to their
home World in thon's Galaxy
damir when Ahsoka Tano follows Morgan
elbeth to peridia in the mouth of A
perill Thon doesn't panic but he doesn't
underestimate her either nor does he
take too seriously or too lightly the
threat posed by a reunited Ahsoka Sabine
and Ezra first he sends balen skull and
shinha after them but to no avail twice
he sends a limited number of Fighters
and troops to deal with them but as he
explains to Morgan eleth and the night
sisters it doesn't matter if they're
killed or left behind all the grand
admiral has to do is keep these Jedi
occupied long enough that they won't be
able to board the ship and stop its
launch when Ahsoka gets a little too
close for comfort Thon sends Morgan to
take care of her this sets up a rematch
of the duel between Ahsoka and Morgan
though Ezra does manage to get on board
the Chimera Sabine stays behind to fight
alongside Ahsoka who slays Morgan but
fails to prevent thon's departure the
last we see of him in season 1 of Ahsoka
Thon is making the hyperspace jump back
to his own Galaxy with a mysterious
Cargo in hand meanwhile Ezra makes his
escape to rendevu with Harrison Doula
whose worst fear has just come true as
she'd long tried to warn mon Matha and
the new Republic Grand Admiral Thon has
returned long live the
empire in recent years thon's story has
evolved to intersect with Anakin
Skywalker the crew of The Ghost and the
casts of both the Mandalorian and Ahsoka
but the character dates back to the time
before the prequel trilogy let alone a
sequel Trilogy or television series
Timothy Zan's original trilogy of thraw
novels air to the Empire dark force
rising and the last command tells a
Complete Tale depicting the battle
between Grand Admiral Thon and George
Lucas's original Trio of Heroes who
appear as older versions of themselves
interestingly these books take place in
9ab y as well and though they're not
canon they involve several recognizable
characters subplots and themes in Zan
series Grand Admiral Thon and Captain
Pelion are interested in the late
emperor cloning operation Han Solo and
Leia Orana are married at this point and
Leia has continued to show promise in
the force like her brother meanwhile the
grand Admiral cooperates and then
clashes with a dark Jedi named joris SEO
in some ways their relationship
resembles the struggle for power between
General hux and kylo ren the books also
feature the Salam lizard-like creatures
that can repel the force and who briefly
appear as sculptures in Star Wars Rebels
but differences abound in the Star Wars
expanded universe too Han and Leia go on
to have three children instead of one
Luke and four sensitive Smuggler turned
Jedi Mara Jade marry before having a son
named Ben the most significant
difference however is thon's eventual
fate of course we don't know what will
become of the canonical Grand Admiral
Thon just yet he's such an integral part
of the franchise at the moment not to
mention one of the most capable villains
Star Wars has ever had so it seems
almost certain that he'll at least
survive until Dave filoni's New Republic
era movie hits theaters it is worth
mentioning that Thon doesn't factor into
the sequel Trilogy so he'll likely be
taken out of the picture sometime before
34 AB but the thron of Legends has
already met his end in the last command
Grand Admiral Thon is betrayed and
murdered by his personal Bodyguard the
noi named Rook the same character who
dies during the attack on lothal in Star
Wars Rebels Rook had recently learned
that the Empire wasn't helping but
hurting his people the noi practically
woried Darth Vader who had promised to
restore their badly polluted ecosystem
in exchange exchange for their
allegiance to the Empire but neither the
Empire nor the Imperial Remnant ever
made good on that promise which Leia
reveals during the events of the
original Thon Trilogy the nree blames
thraw and not the deceased Vader and
begins to place his trust in Leia while
an unsuspecting Thon sits in his chair
communicating with Captain pelot Rook
stabs him in the back from behind Grand
Admiral thon's last words are but it was
so artistically
done
[Music]